I was reading a while back that when you
were preparing for this role you didn't
want to talk to the the real marine just
yet but now that the show is out and it
is so widely beloved right now have you
guys connected over how it all turned
out yeah it's been it's been so
incredible to to see all of the love
that people have for the show and and
how and I can you can really see how
much people are learning from it which
was I think one of the many goals of
making the show is that people could see
it and then learn from it and learn how
trauma really really affects someone for
the rest of their life I so at the
beginning I I remember talking to
Susanna and Lisa about it and it wasn't
that I didn't want to because I actually
I asked about it and I and I was I was I
was honestly unsure I didn't know I
didn't know what what the right thing to
do was and I and I was already so and I
think I can speak for everyone when I
say this that that everyone really felt
so grateful that she was even allowing
us to tell her story in such a big way
on a platform that was gonna be put on a
platform like Netflix and so I remember
talking to them early on and and we all
kind of came to this this this
conclusion I it we didn't we only wanted
to do what she was comfortable with
because again it was such a privilege
that she was allowing us to tell her
story so I only wanted to I only wanted
to do what she wanted to do and I really
did want to respect her privacy because
this is something that still still is
with her and she carries it with her
every day so but it was it really
brought me to tears when Susanna
I think we were doing press somewhere I
forget where we were
for I can't remember where we were but
she came up to me and she said I just
sent you an email I just forwarded you
an email you should really take a look
at it and it was an email that Marie
said to Ken Armstrong that wherever just
it it it was so it was it it really
brought me to tears because she said
that she watched the show and and she
loved it and it it brought her a lot of
closure which is it's just really
overwhelming because it's just out of
everything
that is literally all you could ever ask
for and making and making something like
this you know it's just it they don't
need anything else it's it's such a it's
such an honor to hear that from her
which is it's was it was really a lot
for me it was really really just I I
can't even begin to say how overwhelmed
I was